make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are picking back up again
with the conclusion of infinity conflict
the astral regulator Thanos and in this
video yes Thanos will face off against
the Living Tribunal infinity in eternity
and everybody else that you could think
of and in fact we're actually gonna see
a surprise appearance from a really cool
character right one that we never almost
never get to see but in the last video
we basically kind of had this idea where
you essentially have like future Thanos
right and phantos in this future looked
like eternity but whatever it was it
happened to him he seemingly became this
like omnipotent sort of character the
idea behind this is that that modern-day
Thanos is more or less being guided by
future Thanos so what kind of get an
answer to that question a sort of
explanation as to what's going on but
with eros the brother of feyo's and pit
patrol trying to figure out what Thanos
is doing and then in turn trying to find
a way to defeat him they've essentially
just been following him throughout what
he's been doing right so the idea was
that Thanos had essentially managed to
find some way to acquire a particular
artifact a particular device called the
the astral regulator or the cosmic
regulator and then destroyed mistress
death and really like absorb her essence
into himself and then became the new
death basically means that Thanos now
controls the realm of the afterlife and
so where he essentially teleports away
eros and pip the troll follow him they
don't know exactly where he's going the
best they can do is just kind of jump
forward through time using their device
taken by Kang the Conqueror and then
just try to understand what it is it's
happening right so this is really just
guess and check and so what they do is
jump a year into the future and when
they arrive here in the future Galactus
is ship hit basically just kind of
crash-landed into this realm and when
they start inspecting they start looking
around they basically come to the
realization that Thanos has been
exceedingly busy that not only to Thanos
destroy and absorb Galactus Thanos has
also absorbed the Infinity stones he's
absorbed master order lord chaos the
stranger
saiyr hate mistress love he basically
absorbed all the cosmic entities into
himself and he's been busy now all this
happened off panel I'm not really
skipping over anything we literally go
from one page to this page he's
basically just been absorbing all the
cosmic entities into himself but the
reality of where eurosam pip the troll
are is that it's just kind of like
alright so there's not a whole lot we
can do here but like in the present
moment right now there's nothing we can
do to defeat Thanos like we're gonna
have to find a way to go back in time
and to basically keep this from
happening now here's the here's the cool
thing before you bounce gemstone in
plays time exceed
he's smart in this story he does it in a
really really cool way and that's one of
the things that a lot of writers kind of
run into one of the problems they run
into Bendis ran into that problem when
it came to Matthew Malloy different
writers run into time travel with
different problems and more often than
not it's usually invoked as a means to
end a story jim Starlin passes that and
basically copes with it
in spectacular fashion but the cool
thing about this is that Adam warlock
you know where you end up having pip
Patrol and and and eros who basically
kind of jumped forward to continue their
journey and figuring out what the
endgame of Thanos is Adam warlock is
resurrected and one of the things that
we had talked about in the last video is
that Adam warlock coming back the way
that he did was kind of abnormal it
didn't always happen that way then he
always kind of had a particular form and
function right like a cocoon would
manifest somewhere and Adam warlock
would start to regenerate inside of it
and then ultimately he would come out
he'd make its presence known and
whatever story was going on that
required him to be in that event what
was going on here were things but it was
a reservation process that wasn't normal
right and so what this meant was a Tana
Morlock didn't know entirely what was
going on and so when he basically hops
back up and really kind of asked the
question what's going on with these
changes in my resurrection process he's
met by the arrival of the Living
Tribunal and the Living Tribunal
basically says I'm the one behind all
this like I'm the reason why you're
resurrecting the way that you are now
one of the funny things about this is
that when when Adam warlock starts
asking questions like okay what's going
on like like you know why am I here that
kind of a thing The Living Tribunal says
like we're outside of reality but like
you are outside of the norm now there's
a very particular meaning to that and we
will find out what that meaning is later
on in this video but the two of them get
in a very in-depth discussion and the
reason why is because of course you have
letting Tribunal kind of like is this
multiversal overseer right so even if
the Living Tribunal can be destroyed his
job is to watch the multiverse and to
safeguard it as best he can and so
there's nothing that takes place inside
of a universe across the entirety of the
multiverse the Living Tribunal doesn't
know about whether or not he can stop it
is a whole different argument but he's
always aware of everything that's
happening right so multiversal awareness
it's part and parcel to his role but of
course Adam warlock also addresses the
idea that letting tribunal this version
is basically an alternate reality
version of Adam warlock those guys who
we call that in the aftermath of
Jonathan Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers and secret Wars when the Living
Tribunal and all the cosmic entities
were destroyed
jim Starlin wrote an infinity comic that
was a tie-in to it all more or less
a loose event but the notion was uh the
one above all needed a new Living
Tribunal since the beyonders destroy the
previous one and so Adam warlock from an
alternate reality was made into the New
Living Tribunal so that's just kind of a
quick 30 second or minute explanation
but as to the astral regulator and as to
how it is
Santos has this level of power this all
basically comes through an explanation
from the Living Tribunal and this is a
really really cool concept introduced by
uh by jim Starlin it's actually built on
something else right so for the longest
time when it came to the multiverse and
marvel jim Starlin to introduce
different things like the custodian of
the multiverse and so on and so forth
but the idea here is that we of course
have an infinite number of universes out
there the question that we always sort
of asked here is what keeps one universe
from crossing over into another what jim
Starlin gives us here is the astral
regulator and what he says is that in
every single universe that exists out
there there is an astral regulator right
every universe exists for every
possibility but the linee tributyl
chimes in and says the astral regulators
are basically there to ensure that no
universe crosses over into another this
is in fact Jim starlings adaptation of
DC source wall that's more or less what
this is right the idea that the source
wall that every universe has its own
source wall then the multiverse has its
own source wall and these are literal
barriers around universes and around the
multiverse that are designed to prevent
universes from crossing over in other
universes and multiverses from crossing
over into other multiverse
jim Starlin is essentially taking that
idea and rolling it over and basically
saying the astral regulator is designed
for the purpose of ensuring that no
universe crosses over into another but
it's a very complex network right and so
essentially Thanos taking it has kind of
destabilized things and again we'll talk
more about that here in a little bit but
what the Living Tribunal tells Adam
warlock is Thanos is working towards the
notion of not conquering the universe as
we saw him do in Infinity Gauntlet it's
not like that where he's getting the
Infinity stones slapping him on a glove
and then basically replacing eternity
that also is going for something much
much grander Thanos is trying to become
the entirety of reality and that's why
future Thanos looks the way he does he
looks like eternity because that future
version of Thanos seemingly has achieved
that level of power he is all that is
he's all in existence and so the result
of this is is is you basically have the
tribunal tasking Adam warlock with the
idea of being the person that's going to
essentially find a way to defeat Thanos
now in truth a lot of people could
probably undertake this role but jim
Starlin chose Adam warlock because the
entirety of the infinity line of stories
going from Infinity Gauntlet all the way
up to this story and in really infinity
ending ties into the idea that there's
just something unique and special about
Thanos and Adam warlock now again Adam
warlock outside the norm will kind of
cover that here in a little bit but they
are indeed holy unique characters they
are indeed characters where for the most
part yes they exist in different
realities but they stand away from
everybody else where they stand separate
from everybody else insofar as how they
compare to like all the doctor Strange's
and all the cyclopses and all the
Captain America's and all the
spider-man's and all the Wolverines and
and Phoenix forces and so on and so
forth and so what this does is it
basically leads to this idea that Adam
warlock has to do something in order to
defeat Thanos and so he's kind of tasked
by the tribunal since he's really the
only one that can seemingly pull this
off now pick him back up with eros and
pip Patrol they kind of do this jumping
around the universe right they end up
jumping into the future a little bit
further and they hop skip and around the
universe they go by earth they go by all
these different places the space station
or the celestial head of nowhere the
planet of more the planet of spartax the
brood world a scroll outpost Rigel all
these different places they've all been
destroyed by Thanos right like all life
has been totally eradicated by Thanos
like even down to the microscopic level
nothing exists there anymore and so what
this does is it picks up with a living
tribunal meeting with the one above all
now we never get to see this in Marvel
Comics we never really see what happens
when the Living Tribunal meets with up
one above all that usually never ever
ever happens and in fact as far as I'm
aware this is the first time in Marvel
Comics we've actually gotten to see the
two of them converse in this capacity
usually it's the Liney tribunals saying
something like I represent a power
that's beyond everything or whatever it
is you know he's just super Opie beyond
beyond Omega level is what he is but the
one above all basically tells the living
tribe you know what's going on in this
one universe threatens all of creation
right it threatens all things in
existence what's happened here is
threatening everything now one of the
cool things that goes on is the one
above all's face shifts he changes from
one one race to another to another to
another so it was kind of a cool theme
to kind of see this melding and
switching and changing that well the one
above all is not a finite construct
right like he's just kind of this
representation of everything that exists
out there and what the one above all
says is this astral
later is designed to regulate the
entirety of the multiverse that is not
as small beans as a living tribe you
don't thought it was right the limit
tribunal looked at this and said okay so
basically Thanos taking the astral
regulator creates a cosmic imbalance and
my job is to enforce that and because
he's kind of outside the norm and he has
a level of power and so on and so forth
Adam warlock you go take care of it what
the one above all says is no you fail to
grasp the complexity of this man this is
super important because it hits at this
idea that despite all of his vaunted
power the Living Tribunal is not an
immutable all-knowing force right like
he's basically he's screwed up here it's
really what it is right he misjudged he
misunderstood the complexity and how
extreme the situation is what the one
above all says is the Astro regulator of
each universe yes they exist their
purpose is to keep a universe from
crossing over with another but the truth
of this is that they're all tied into a
network so what's basically gone on here
if Thanos was playing a giant game of
Jenga and he's starting to pull out the
wrong pieces and it's only a matter of
time before this whole thing comes
crashing down by taking this Astro
regulator and pulling it away from his
role and then repurposing it for the for
the reason of giving himself omnipotence
he's upset the multiversal balance right
the balance of all existence not only
that what he's doing can actually happen
he could become the entirety of reality
itself in essence the one above all now
views Thanos as a credible threat and
that's what's so crazy about this right
Thanos is at a level of power now for
the one above all is legitimately
concerned and at the end of the day it
all comes down to Adam warlock to be the
one to pull it off and so that's why all
these things are really sort of crazy
here that's why it's so chaotic it's
because what we do is we basically jump
to you know present day Thanos for lack
of a better word whose absorbed all
these cosmic entities meeting with his
future self right the one that is
essentially merged with all of reality
and the whole reason behind this is the
fact that future Thanos is is fearful of
the fact that somebody will figure out
what he's doing and basically stop his
younger self and that's the cool thing
here right this is Jim saw and playing
it smart with reality that we would look
at this and we would say okay so if
present-day Thanos is talking to his
future self and his future self becomes
a connected to all of reality he becomes
everything in existence presumably you
know transcending the one above all and
the Living Tribunal in all that then
like why would he concern himself with
like making sure his younger self gets
there and the reason why is because
anybody could screw it up at any point
in time it's one thing to it
give that role but the reality of what
Thanos has learned with regards to the
multiverse is a fact that there's an
infinite number of realities out there
and anything can happen
somebody can pop up they can be at the
right place at the right time and so
it's essentially guiding himself right
making sure bit like the things that
could get in his way
don't get in his way right that just
because he ended up in this future you
know and and became this being doesn't
mean that it's guaranteed right like if
for example he was supposed to kill Adam
warlock at a particular point in time
and he didn't everything gets thrown off
and any number of things can cause that
to happen right any number of things can
can get in there and so what you do is
you pick up basically with eros and with
with pit Patrol kind of coming to this
conclusion is it's sort of a red herring
here the way jim Starlin plays it
because it's like okay so like they're
gonna go back in time they're gonna kill
Faneuil so he's a baby and basically
stop the future okay so like this is
like and there are some writers out
there who would say and this is how we
in the story guys thanks for watching
you know jim Starlin does this and
before eros can pull it off Adam warlock
pops up and says if you do that nothing
will happen it's not going to work
because what's going to happen here is
things are gonna be worse and this is
really jim Starlin tying in to
everything he's done with regards to
Adam warlock and Thanos in the entire
infinity series right the relationship
between the two and when jim Starlin was
riding the old adam warlock comics the
relationship between adam warlock and
Thanos was at Thanos had actually come
to the aid of Adam warlock and helping
Adam defeat his own future evil
counterpart The Magus you know Magus is
attempt to basically gain the the
Infinity Gauntlet for himself during the
events of infinity war Thanos being part
of warlock in the infinity watch and
basically having the reality stone and
then giving a false stone to the Magus
is what led to nagisa's defeat at the
end of the whole thing right he had an
affinity gauntlet but he wasn't
all-powerful because it didn't have all
the Infinity stones
what Adam says here is that if eros
kills Thanos as a baby that it means at
each one of those pivotal moments
throughout the entirety of the universe
when Thanos helps him defeat the Magus
when Thanos gives the Magus a false
reality stone when each one of those
things takes place did it won't happen
and the future that's going to come out
of that is going to be a future where
the Magus will dominate all of reality
and put the kind of things that Thanos
did during Infinity Gauntlet and
infinity war and infinity Crusade and
the infinity siblings and all that kind
of stuff
it'll put all that to shame and so of
course eros basically backs off his
actions and destroying Santos as a baby
and they essentially teleport back to
the modern day or 2000
at the time this is being done to the
base of where eros is operating at and
when the question is what do we do here
you know if if this plan of killing
Santos is a baby is not gonna work
then what plan do you have and Adam
warlock says this and he kills he kills
eros hip Patrol begins to freak out but
the responsive Adam warlock is according
to The Living Tribunal this is the only
thing that's going to work and so what
we do is we basically jump back to the
future with with Thanos
who's essentially absorbed all these
various cosmic entities and this this
you know what we'll call him like
primitive Thanos more or less in
comparison to his like ultra powerful
future counterpart but primitive Thanos
is met by the arrival of eternity and he
was told by his future version eternity
and infinity are really a couple of the
last stops that you have before this
entire thing is is taking care of right
before it's all done and so what this
does is it leads to a conflict between
the two now the cool thing about this
and I love how jim Starlin plays on this
Thanos this is not his first time up to
back he's done this dance he's played
this game he understands the
significance of eternity and infinity
the power that they wield with Thanos is
not concerned about either of them
because the power he possesses in the
form of the astral regulator is way
beyond the power of infinity and
eternity and so where they show up here
and they basically start using their
various abilities to try to destroy
Thanos we jump back to eros and eros of
course having been killed in the modern
day ends up travelling to the realm of
mistress death because at the time that
he died
Thanos had not killed and absorbed
mistress death yet and so what it meant
is that basically being their mistress
death is aware of the plot that Thanos
has in his attempt to like basically
show up on her doorstep and kill her at
some future point in time which kind of
makes sense being a cosmic entity that
understands the notions of like life and
death and things like that it makes
sense that she would be aware of that
and so with that being the case
she believes eros is there as a spy and
so in order to resolve the situation she
banishes
eros from her realm that action right
there is what saves all things in
existence like that action right there
is why eros was so important and that's
why I Adam warlock killed him is because
that one thing is going to essentially
be this saving grace really sorry sumit
is buttin stuff transitioning back to
Thanos facing off against eternity and
infinity the reality is they're really
more pomp and circumstance here than
anything anything else they're blowing a
bunch of hot air
therefore all their talk of like you're
going to fall we're going to destroy you
all that kind of stuff it's really just
more pride than anything else in the
face of the astral regulator and the
power that it represents and the face of
all these vaunted abilities that he has
infinity in eternity Falk and it's kind
of crazy because the conflict between
the two of them basically spans like all
things in existence right it expands all
of time and space across the universe
itself all time across the universe like
everything across the entirety of the
universe it's felt by them from the
universe is very beginnings all the way
to its very end the point at which it
dies like this is what we're talking
about here this is the kind of level of
power that we're discussing because
that's what these characters represent
infinity represents time and eternity
reveries in space and so to fight them
is to fight all of time and space and so
that's why these these conflicts between
these beings literally have shockwaves
across the entirety of the universe's
history and the space the universe
occupies it's like being able to witness
an explosion all at the same time right
so like there's like an atomic bomb that
goes off or some kind of explosion
doesn't matter what it is but like you
see it and then a person from 500 years
ago sees the exact same explosion and a
person in a thousand years sees the
exact same explosion some kind of an
event across all time in space I know
it's super meta and I know it seems kind
of kind of crazy and a little
mind-bending but that's what we're
talking about when we're talking about
cosmic entities but regardless of how
hard they fight and regardless of what
tricks they pull up their sleeve in the
sense of infinity manipulating time and
trying to like age Thanos and you know
try to destroy Thanos and the collapse
of his physical form all that kind of
stuff none of it works and the two of
them are absorbed into themselves and
when that happens
Thanos was confronted with the with a
living tribunal and the Liberty tribunal
basically appears here and says this
cannot be allowed to stand this amount
of power that you have what you've done
is created an incredible imbalance in
the universe itself more so than that
you threaten the entirety of the
multiverse there's nothing to negotiate
here there's nothing for us to talk
about you Thanos are going to have to
fall and so what we do is we jump back
to eros and so eros resurrecting
basically coming back from the dead
having been banished from mistress death
this is why the Living Tribunal was
referring to you by being outside the
norm that Adam warlock can never die
Adam warlock will live forever he will
always resurrect no matter how you kill
him no matter what means it is that his
physical body is destroyed somebody
somewhere will be walking and like
they'll die they'll just kill over from
a heart attack or they'll be hit by a
bus and they'll be used as a method by
which Adam warlock returns Thanos has
been banished from the realm of mistress
death he was banished from her realm
long before the story took place right
he was banned he can never ever die
like
now eros is the exact same way they
exist outside the norm because they're
immutable forces now right they're not
really on par with cosmic entities and
so far as like they're all-powerful it's
not really that way it's simply the
natural order of things which is things
are born and things die and then there's
them they're outside the norm they're
outside the natural order and so that's
the reason why why eros is so important
here is because with him and Adam
warlock working together presumably they
should be able to defeat Thanos and so
following this we pick up basically with
this massive destruction you know
they're this massive explosion seemingly
in the entirety of this system and the
defeat of the Living Tribunal and that's
why this is important is because when
you think of a fight between the Living
Tribunal and you think of the living
tribunals destruction most likely you
think of Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers because that's really the only
time that we ever saw that happening
like the only time we saw before that
was during Marvel the end and it was
really more of Thanos absorbing all of
reality into himself and then recreating
it again usually when you think of like
an extremely powerful being like the
Living Tribunal being destroyed you
think of like this massive explosion of
energy that would just shatter the
entirety of the multiverse it's like
it's like it's like grabbing a brick and
just throwing it into a into a glass
house right it's just it's gonna shatter
the entire thing like it's gonna it's
gonna destroy some part of the glass
house and the rest of its gonna collapse
under its own weight
right that's kind of how you you would
seen that situation to be the way this
plays out though is again it's basically
just this idea of fan oohs absorbing the
Living Tribunal into himself but that's
where Thanos is now at this moment right
now
Thanos has absorbed the Living Tribunal
into himself or at least that seems to
be the case now things are gonna be
explained a little bit more at a future
point in time but like Thanos basically
jumps in with his future counterpart
like starts talking to him and and
essentially his future counterpart says
you are now where I am right like we are
now where we're supposed to be you have
achieved the level of power I've wanted
you to achieve we are now one and
literally they merge into a singular
being right now this is just Jim
Sterling's way of rectifying the times
true the future version of Thanos got
modern-day Thanos to this level of power
and the two of them are now occupying
the same space at the same time the
truth is that they're a singular being
rightly the same person both cannot
exist at the same time and so they
basically become the singular person and
when that happens Thanos says now the
real game begins now I fan owes Who am
essentially the sum total of all of
reality will go forward and I will face
off against the one above all but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you
no here to comment explain to make sure
you guys at the sub button to become
part of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a link and
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]